thank you very much everybody who's
joining us on the live stream today
and
those members that we have on zone
we have uh
mrs coate
councillor abbott councillor lois and
councillor clark
hello team
um we're going to kick off today with
some apologies for from his worship the
mia and both uh councillor pottinger as
well
second district
uh any declarations of interest with
today's items
no one on zoom either
we should move the apologies we accepted
i'll move the apologies be accepted
thank you councillor
all those in favor second head of north
carolina
thank you carried
any declarations of interest
no
i don't think we need to carry those
nobody's everybody's happy
we've got
nothing in public forum today um and so
then we'll move on to tab item number
four which is the minutes of our last
meeting held on the 5th of july
any discussion on those correct they'll
be confirmed thank you council ludlow
and the secondary thank you councillor
sofa all those in favor all right
all right
i'm not seeing any descent so we'll
carry that
we then have uh item number five which
is our general policies reserve
management plan
um today we will have um i think cassie
here to speak to this yep i can see some
waving over there
and caroline rayne as well
to take us through
the policies reserve management plan
thank you very much for being here today
guys
kiara thank you
okay so general policies reserve
management plan
um just some key points to put across is
um so when we develop a management plan
there's a requirement under the reserves
act that we need to
consult with the community and so this
first step is mainly about creating an
awareness to the public before we go
into a full consultation on the draft
when that's prepared next year
um we've been working closely with
communications and strategy and policy
to ensure that around this time of the
year is seen as fairly light for
consultation so it's a great baseline
for us to actually get that awareness
out there now and
having this general policies management
plan will ensure that it encompasses all
of our reserves and cemeteries and
rationalizing the number of management
plans produced as well
awesome now
this is just a way of sort of
consolidating everything that we've got
going on at the moment because if
i've got my understanding correct we've
actually got a lot of individual plans
across a lot of reserves
which doesn't quite
make sense
yeah it just ensures that we have the
best efficient uses of our resources in
our time so we're not having to repeat a
lot of the policies across our reserves
and also when we do go out for future
drafts
that go under review that we're just
looking at one base
reserve management plan we will of
course um look at specific management
plans for those key reserves like
queen's park and the premier reserves
which are listed in the in the report
awesome um can you tell me a little bit
about what we will expect to see from
the consultation from the public's
perspective
the first stage is hard to tell because
really it's creating an awareness and
really getting an understanding of who's
interested and what people want to see
so it's just getting it out there to
everybody that we can so that they can
um have a chance to or an opportunity to
provide that feedback initially
um and then when we get the draft back a
lot of i imagine there'll be a lot more
feedback because people would have had a
chance to read what we're proposing on
on different types of policies
brilliant we've got two recommendations
here one is to receive the report
general policies reserve management plan
and the second is to endorse proceeding
to advertise for submissions over the
months of august and september 2022 on
the production of the new general
policies reserve management plan
um do we have anybody that would like to
speak on the letter
ms coopt i mean good wrong one cook all
right
that's wrong
um casey i'm aware that the um sandy
point
is actually out for consultation now
so
this is a little bit chicken in the egg
what's going to happen if
um
some of the underlying principles
conflict with what is the outcome for
sandy point so what will be stated in
the general policies is anything that's
noted in the specific so for the sandy
point management plan that will trump
the general policies because that's
specific to that
reserve
thank you for that
any further
comments happy to move the
recommendations madam chair thank you
council sopher and thank you miss cook
we've got a mover and a seconder all
those in favor
aye
carried
thank you
next we have our activities report
so we have some of our group managers
here to speak to that today
about
this is a
quite a general report that covers a
wide range of activities across council
so those of you that are watching on the
on the zoom stream or those that happen
to be here in the public gallery today
um
we've got quite a few updates throughout
this one
for the uh splash palace aspect uh take
it as red now this was the
report for june uh at the last meeting
councillor um craic had asked a few
questions about the performance of the
first week so with your indulgence i'll
give you some stats even though
it's actually next month's yeah
but i do think you'll be interested the
opening specials and promotion went
really really well
but here are some figures for you
there was 230
000 in uh excluding gst in revenue for
the month and that's 17 to the 21 22
total revenue target so that was
demonstrates the um
uh how popular it was and also within
that that's part of that money is made
up of 28 000 for the cafe and 14 000 for
retail both of those are the highest
that they've been in the past three
years so that's a pretty good sign that
uh increased participation the layout
and everything is is doing what we hoped
it would do so some really good um
positive numbers there also 866 new
members obviously there'll be a
contraction there'll be a lot of people
taking the opportunity to to get it
there and we won't it won't settle down
for a few months but again a really
positive indication
the only remaining thing in that
in the refurbishment is the
bulkhead which is just been delayed
because of international shipping that's
coming from america i believe that's
correct isn't it yeah other than that
all going on target and looking good
uh kyota just a quick update on uh parks
probably the great news in regards to
bluff is
the awarding of the tourism
infrastructure fund for the bluff
active recreation precinct we think
that's going to be
combined with council's funding going to
be a great investment down there and
it's going to unlock quite a lot of
extra
recreational opportunity and something
that's going to be
awesome for our wider
community as well as the buffer
community specifically
and just to touch on
the works continue
through both design and the construction
phase with airport ave on the stead
street project so making good progress
there um
and happy to take any questions on
unless michael dave's got any other
updates on his party infrastructure
group
thank you through yourself chair um just
like to highlight there's been we've
started the roading repair season um
obviously we've
done quite a bit in relation to crack
sealed completion but
the actual road ceiling component won't
be happening until slightly later on
into the season when the wetter weather
is
obviously slightly better so
that will be coming up
towards the end of august i believe we
start
doing our ceiling road work so
something to look forward to
uh councillor abbott i think you were
first there
um i actually think it was graham but
never mind sorry about that
just interested um and i'd rather call
it bandage ceiling than cracks even um
those are
silver slippery things on the road is
that what they are like sneaky things
through yourself chair that is exactly
what they are it's that's why they call
it the bandage ceiling because it looks
like a bandage sitting across the road
yeah it looks like it's slithering the
snake but i suppose the better on the
roadway than elsewhere
which is seals the seals the road
thank you
councillor lewis
just a general question the tourist
their infrastructural funding
it's a strange amount a very exact
amount on what basis was that given do
you know or will there be a shortfall
possible or short for is that worked on
a particular budget or how did they
arrive that figure
uh look i've got the parks and
recreation team here who might be able
to talk a little bit about the funding
and they're looking at me as well
we put a total funding application of of
1.1
million dollars for that additional
piece of work for the tourism
infrastructure fund
and
the fund notification we received from
um mb was for the amount that they've
granted down here now how they've
determined the exact figure
um we're unsure um caroline can you add
anything to that answer
no steve that's pretty much exactly as
it occurred we put in a full bid and the
award was for 981 000 um for the tourism
infrastructure from the tourism
infrastructure fund but there was very
little additional detail as to how
they'd come up to that figure for us
all right okay thank you very much for
that
but
in addition to that my original question
is that kind of leave us a shortfall
that we're going to have to fund and
have we got that in the budget to do so
through you the chair um the
money that we actually put forward in
the original bid does include what we
put as third party funding so we are
going to be able to deliver the core
elements of that
active recreation hub and there there
may be some additional
enhancements to that that we won't be
able to do with this base funding
thank you
thanks councillor lewis i'm just uh
expanding on that we had uh quite a
wealth of people come through uh through
the consultation process last with the
um annual plan and the long-term plan
asking for us to
uh invest in
toilets in the car parking area for like
that sort of facilitated around the
mountain biking areas
is that included in this yeah correct
that's included in that and that's part
of council's contribution to that
overall project brilliant i think well
they'll be a sector of the community
that will be really heavy
awesome i think next was councillor
soper
thanks madam chair i was just going to
comment having traveled by plane
yesterday the airport avenue is already
looking better
thank you
uh and
councillor clark is that thumb is that a
hangover thumb
hitchhiking
so you're on mute
a couple of questions one in relation to
space palace on and the end
participation figures for steve
um
when you compare this current financial
year that's just ended and you look at
the 20
20 21 year which is a preceding line
which was a closed period is a
significant drop-off in uh participation
uh by my assessment
more more than a hundred and twenty
hundred and thirty
thousand
so if we had if we had the uh splash
palace closed for five weeks that that
you'd expect that to be 10 of your
client period so putting that aside
we've still got quite a shortfall um
about 80 000 difference between those
two years factoring in the closure
period so does the do the staff have any
idea about
why the participation rate is down
through madam chair uh look part of this
promotion was to get people re-engaged
with the service because we had observed
that not only there was covert impacts
but there's that habitual thing that was
lost so part of that promotion was to
try and address that to get the
participation in that habitual
thing of going to the pool normalized
again so we were aware of that
trying to look back at past years we've
got
you know a couple of years of pretty
patchy data and it is hard to compare uh
one year to the other but we're
confident that we're on the upward trend
now
and if i may add to that
you also recall back in august we did go
into
a four-week lockdown and then as we
moved through the alert levels the
the pools management had to in order to
facilitate community swimming we had to
have a lane gap between each swimmer we
could only have one swimmer per lane and
so we had some very very tight
restrictions on the operations which
also had quite a significant impact over
a longer period of time
in those numbers so the combination of
um
both the the close downs the shutdown or
the lockdown sorry and then the
restriction on operations has has
compiled into what we've seen as
the numbers
today
and just just as a follow-up question to
that steve um
do these sort of uh drop off and the
slope pick up does that change our views
on a potential second uh
swimming pool going forward is that
something we just have to wait and see a
little bit
the the just through madam chair the the
second pool of hydrotherapy uh and spa
and further developments wasn't based
around increased participation or
responding to an increased participation
it was about opening up a new market so
it shouldn't put us off at all
thank you for that finally for steve the
issue of the steve street stock bank
climate resilience project update
um
two things in there uh do we know what
the budget is for that upgrade i mean
the presentation we had from waihepa
roonaka
last week i think was yeah it was really
positive the artwork seemed really neat
but of course um
no factor in here about what the cost is
likely to be so that's one issue the
other issue for me in that presentation
was the location of a whale's tail which
i thought was really neat
um but i'm just wondering whether in the
band on the
airport arcade is actually the best
place for it to be
given that um
a cultural narrative is not just for
incoming uh tourists for one of the
better words or travelers it's also for
the local people as well
and i'm just wondering whether that
that wales tube could be better located
on either side of the small bridge that
goes over the east street
we've got quite a bit of land on either
side then it could be quite a feature
so that's close to where the steer
street warfare is on that side or that
big open place that's on the right hand
on the left hand side
coming in
through you madam chair um
at this point we're expecting a quantity
surveyor to come back with uh
the
i guess the
the updated estimated costs of the
cultural narrative that has been part of
the design teams approach already and
they have been looking at ensuring that
we fit to the budget
and so the presentation was provided
does
meet that budget but we're waiting on
the final confirmation that's going to
be a couple of weeks away at this point
uh in terms of the partnership that
we've got with the roonaka and in terms
of location
it's certainly something we can
pass feedback back on to but it fits
within the broader
cultural narrative of both how we've
dealt with the stock bank and in terms
of how we're positioning
the airport avenue in particular i'm
probably not
able to answer any further specifics on
how we've landed on that but can
certainly ask the design team to give us
the advice as to what they have
considered as the appropriate location
thank you
thank you for that steve um i would like
to just say that
i know councillor clark you wouldn't
have meant any offense by it by saying
the word artwork but i really would like
to stress that this is a full cultural
narrative experience like there will
there's
a whole lot of history and significance
that will be built into the placement
and the positioning and the the general
story and the craft behind it rather
than it just being a pretty piece of
artwork so i just wanted to
really clarify that um
did anybody else have anything to say
to the activities report
thank you miss cook
firstly just um to
comment on the way that the
report from the roading
i really like that it appeals to my
sense of
the understanding that i can follow that
visual pathway um
quite a lot of information
attached alongside it but visually quite
um impactful
just a couple of comments
this
the airport avenue um contract
with tita tani who will be speaking with
us later is not part of milihiku
regeneration titani is a separate
separate entity in its own right
and i suppose it goes in concept with
the
sculptural piece
which is specifically targeted to be on
airport avenue as opposed to being part
of the stead street project so
in our narrative we see them as
it's what hawkeye's narrative we see
them as separate entities
we were asked to provide something for
airport avenue so that is the difference
um just in general the um
i think there this report has a lot of
information over a lot of different
parts of our
infrastructure that i think it was
behoove people to read because i think
the three waters renewals which is
something that is top of people's minds
at the moment to see that it is ongoing
the repairs to the roads to see that
they're ongoing business as usual has
not stopped because we're having all
these big discussions and i think that
um
it's important that the public know that
we don't just
sit around talking but the staff are out
there doing the doing and
we're getting these interesting reports
so thank you very much to the staff who
provide them
thank you ms cook i quite agree with you
it's really good this is a great avenue
for us to sell some of the really
successful fantastic things that are
going on in the community do we have any
more comments on the activities report
no one from zone
no one from the floor
all right we had a mover in secondary
which was um counselor sopa and ms cook
uh
all in favour
hi
carrick
thank you very much and that brings us
to the end of our public meeting if i
could have a mover and secondary for us
to move into public excluded for the
reasons listed on the screen
councilman lewis i think i think
councillor lois thank you hard to keep a
tab of zoe main floor and
council scout thank you very much and
welcome to the meeting before sorry i
didn't get to say that all the time
thank you all those in favor all right
carried and closed thank you members of
the public for being here and thank you
very much